[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Serbia is only in the news when it
defends Novak Djokovic that pro tennis
player who doesn't want to get
vaccinated so then who cares about
Serbia well without going any further
Putin cares about Serbia remember the
speech in which he announces the
invasion of Ukraine I am sure you have
all seen some excerpts of the speech
well pay attention to this part is
Europe
is
infrastructure Putin recited all the
wrongs the West has done against
Russia's interests since the
disintegration of the Soviet Union
that's what the Russian president was
talking about when he mentioned the
Belgrade bombings I know what many of
you are thinking especially those of you
over 30 Belgrade bombings that sounds
familiar I've heard about that exactly
we're talking about an episode of the
Balkan War one of the bloodiest
conflicts in modern history a war that
took place on European soil around the
time when almost all of you who watch
visualpolitik were born today Serbia is
a country with fewer than 7 million
inhabitants it has never been a
superpower nor does it have significant
natural resources however this country
is where World War One and the Balkan
war broke out so the question we ask you
today is why is Serbia so troubled what
happened in that Balkan war that we saw
as children on the news and why does
Putin bring her up in his speeches what
are the ties between Serbia and Russia
Today on visualpolitik we're going to
answer all of these questions but first
let's look at some history
[Music]
Yugoslavia the land of the South Slavs
for centuries the Balkans were a buffer
between two empires the Austrian and the
ottoman it was at the end of the 19th
century that the serbs gained
independence from Turkish Rule and
proclaimed the kingdom of Serbia the
problem is that the Balkans are home to
many different ethnic groups each with
its own language religion and National
sentiment some serbs did not live within
the New Kingdom of Serbia many lived in
Bosnia Herzegovina which was still a
province within the austro-halgarian
Empire well a group of Serb separatists
organized the sarajeval bombing and the
rest is history
in 1914 Gabriel princip a Serbian
nationalist assassinated Archduke Franz
Ferdinand heir to the throne of the
austro-hungarian Empire consequently
Austria-Hungary declared war on the
kingdom of Serbia setting in motion all
of the military alliances that had been
woven in Europe in the preceding decades
in fact Russia itself was drawn into the
conflict as a result of its pact with
Serbia the first world war had just
begun in San Diego
Serbia was on the site of the victors in
the Great War this meant that the
kingdom considerably expanded its
territories at last an independent
Yugoslavia was a reality a country that
would unite the southern Slavs but
remember the South Slavs were divided
into a lot of different ethnicities and
not all of them were clear that they
wanted to belong to the same state
foreign
supported Hitler in order to create
their own independent Croatia this is
how one of the most bloodthirsty regimes
in history came into being the ustaza
side note I won't go into details but
the ustaza were so brutal that even the
Nazis went so far as to try some of its
top commanders for crimes against
humanity the Nazis but that's a subject
for another video the important thing is
that during World War II the partisans
managed to drive the Nazis out of the
area and these partisans of the
Communist ideology had this man you see
on the screen as their leader
foreign
from the very beginning it was clear for
Marshall Tito that his main task was to
unite the various National groups in
modern Yugoslavia so he recognized their
rights by giving the status of Republic
to Bosnia Herzegovina Croatia Slovenia
Macedonia Montenegro and Serbia itself
in the old Yugoslavia national
oppression by the great Serb capitalist
Clique meant strengthening the economic
exploitation of the oppressed peoples in
the new socialist Yugoslavia the
existing equality of Rights for all
nationalities has made it impossible for
One National Group to impose economic
exploitation upon another Joseph brought
Tito and I know what you are thinking as
a good communist country Yugoslavia
would be a satellite of Moscow wouldn't
it well nothing of the sort Yugoslavia
had liberated itself thanks to the
partisan struggle and Tito rejected any
interference from Moscow in fact for
most of the 20th century yugoslavs were
the lucky ones they could travel and do
business with everybody both capitalists
and communists
Yugoslavia was a socialist Federation in
which each Republic had its own
Parliament and a high level of autonomy
decisions affecting the whole country
were made jointly by a council with a
representative from each Republic the
Yugoslav constitution of 1974 increased
the autonomy within the Republic of
Serbia of the provinces of Kosovo and
vodineva which became represented in the
Council of Yugoslavia this meant that
these autonomous provinces had the same
power in Yugoslavia as Serbia itself
because not everything was so Rosy in
1980 Tito died and Yugoslavia went into
a brutal economic crisis this included
hyperinflation of Venezuelan levels and
of course when everything's going well
everyone is Friends the serbs the crew
acts the slovenians the kosovars but
when they go wrong you think that the
ruler in power is only trying to benefit
his own people and hurt years
in the late 1980s Kosovo was a powder
kick Kosovo serbs felt oppressed by the
ethnic Albanian majority at the head of
Kosovo and its Communist Party were the
Kosovo albanians the conflict was
already on the streets in order to calm
things down the Serbian Communist Party
sent its second in command and then
slodivan milosevic came along then the
cost of our serbs said to him hey defend
our rights because the kosovar albanians
are harassing us check this out
[Applause]
foreign
adopted a very popular nationalism among
the Serbian population in 1989 he became
president of the whole of Yugoslavia one
of his first measures was to eliminate
the autonomy of the provinces of Kosovo
and vodanyeva winning the votes in the
council that governed Yugoslavia in view
of the power accumulated by Serbian
nationalism Slovenia and Croatia the
richest republics of Yugoslavia opted to
declare their independence and that is
how the Balkan War began
foreign
[Music]
War
the First Republic to become independent
was Slovenia a few serbs lived in
Slovenia so there were no major problems
really of course there was a war with
Yugoslavia but only lasted 10 days
however the case of the cruets was very
different Croatia did have serbs living
in his territory so Belgrade sent the
Yugoslav Army to confront the Crux the
Croatian war of independence lasted for
years it was quite a bloodbath but
nothing compared to Bosnia
[Music]
in this case we are talking about three
sides fighting each other the bosniaks
of Muslim religion were fighting for
survival the others encouraged by Serbia
and Croatia wanted to divide up Bosnia
they were the Catholic Bosnian croats
and the Bosnian serbs who were Eastern
Orthodox Christians the Bosnian serbs
went so far as to create their own
independent republic the surpska
Republic I'm not making that up
s-r-p-s-k-a sirska this is where the
siege of Sarajevo which many of you will
surely remember from your childhood news
broadcasts came about this is when the
U.N decreed a no-fly zone and who was
defending the bosnians airspace exactly
NATO that explains why in 1994 NATO shot
down up to four Bosnian Serb planes and
what did Russia think about it well the
truth is that they barely protested come
to think of it Yeltsin had just bombed
his own Russian Parliament so he had
mother matters to attend to that
explains statements like this one the
Bosnia dilemma Yeltsin warns serps to
stop attacks the Kremlin leaders sharply
worded statement show shift in attitude
toward long-term allies the thing is
that the Bosnian serbs are tougher than
Wolverine's adamantium they saw no
reason to stop the war not even after
bosniaks and Bosnian croats joined
forces against them they were winning
but in 1995 everything changed
the Bosnian croats gained the support of
the Croatian Army the Bosnian serbs
decided to die by killing and then
perpetrated the sebranica massacre the
biggest genocide of the Bosnian War as
things were getting very ugly NATO
launched operation deliberate force a
three-week air campaign that forced the
Bosnian serbs to negotiate the Russians
protested but understood that it was the
only way to end the war so Moscow
participated along with the West in the
negotiations of the Dayton Accords at
last the Balkans breathed a sigh of
relief well it is true that not all of
them did for the serbs the Dayton
Accords were like the Serbian version of
the Treaty of Versailles the treaty
signed after World War One the
humiliated Germany and fueled German
Ultra nationalism at the end of the day
a humiliating
Bosnian serbs rejects Dayton agreement
threaten Accord but the story does not
end there the calm in the Balkans lasted
until 1998. then a low-intensity War
Began between the Yugoslav forces and
the Kosovo albanians who wanted
independence from Serbia
the West punished milosevic with
International sanctions for his
repression in Kosovo they had no effect
so NATO forced Belgrade to negotiate to
return Kosovo to autonomy but milosevic
refused the involvement of international
troops and this is where we come to the
bombings Vladimir Putin was talking
about at this point NATO was then
legitimized to bomb Yugoslavia without
the approval of the U.N the bombings
lasted two and a half months and were
condemned by Russia in the end milosevic
surrendered and Kosovo became a kind of
un protectorate over the years it ended
up declaring that its independence with
the approval of the West something used
by Putin to validate the annexation of
Crimea
[Music]
of course
Russian forces participated in the
international contingent that occupied
Kosovo but they were on their own in
fact the first armed clash between
Russia and NATO almost took place when
the Russians went ahead and took over
Pristina airport there were more than
words but fortunately no one fired the
first shot since then the Balkans have
endured a fragile balance of forces that
could destabilize at any moment and more
so with what is happening in Ukraine
check this out
Russia's friends
[Music]
the invasion of Crimea taught us
something that had seemed impossible
that the maps of Europe can change at
any time since then Serbia has increased
its investment in defense by 70 up to
1.4 billion dollars a year coincidence
here on visual partic we'd like to think
we know better this is like Paris
Saint-Germain in soccer you don't spend
millions of dollars and then not show
off your power
Serbia has just ordered two c295s from
Airbus as previously negotiated with
Israel for the purchase of anti-tank
missiles and with turkey for the drones
that Azerbaijan took such advantage of
to defeat Armenia in the recent conflict
it has also purchased Chinese combat
drones Russian helicopters and a French
surface-to-air missile system in
addition in recent years Russia and
Belarus have donated 10 mega 29 Fighters
and the Kremlin also gave it 30 tanks at
armored personnel carriers while selling
it an air defense system
now don't think that we're seeing look
how bad this Arabs are because the
United States has also given Blackhawk
helicopters to Croatia what we want to
highlight is that yes for two decades
the countries that made up the former
Yugoslavia have been trying to rebuild
themselves some have done better than
others but they are also re-arming and
Serbia is spending more on its Army than
Albania Bosnia Montenegro Kosovo and
North Macedonia combined
[Music]
by itself this fact would mean nothing
but last fall over a minor disagreement
with Kosovo Belgrade sent warplanes near
the border and deployed armored vehicles
to intimidate its former Province but
looking back at the wars of the past
more worrying is the rise of nationalist
discworth within the Serbia's government
listen to its minister of the Interior
Alexander vulen at the so-called
assembly of all serbs and at the end of
May this year
allusions to creating a Serbian world
are viewed with suspicion by all
countries in the area where there is a
large Serb Community there is a fear
that this idea of a greater Serbia will
provoke a return to Arms in any case it
is one thing that Serbia does not want
to impose sanctions on Putin's Russia or
that it has even taken advantage of the
situation to obtain an agreement from
the supply of Russian gas under very
advantageous conditions it is quite
another thing for Serbia to take the
initiative
[Music]
but the issue the current situation in
Serbia its relations with Russia and
also with the European Union is
something that we will discuss in an
upcoming video that we will upload very
soon here on visualpolitik stay tuned
because for sure there are many things
that will surprise you about this
unusual Balkan country
Belgrade officially still wants to join
the European Union and the country is
practically surrounded by NATO except
for one place Bosnia Herzegovina a
federal state in which the Republica
serpska is an entity of its own we will
talk about bosnia's soon here on
visualpolitik because it is a very
special country a country with three
different presidents and within that
country milorad dodike the leader of the
Bosnian serbs has raised the tone he is
threatening to break up the country he's
been doing so since last fall when he
met with the Russian foreign minister
information came out of that meeting
that the Bosnian serbs had asked Moscow
for arms assistance listen to what
milorad dodik says about the
independence of Republica serps
[Music]
another war in Europe would be a way to
destabilize the West with Russia hit so
hard by sanctions we cannot rule out
that the Kremlin has put Bosnia in its
sights it is also true that out of this
whole story of how the former Yugoslavia
disintegrated there is one real victim
and that is the bosnians but as I've
already told you we will talk about that
in another video because now the
question is over to you do you think
Russia is ready to reopen Old Wounds in
the Balkans do you see the possibility
of War breaking out again in the former
Yugoslavia you can leave me your answer
in the comments below as always don't
forget that here on visualpolitik we
release new videos every week so
subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss any of them if you enjoyed this
video like it so we know and I'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]